well hey everybody what's going on it's
Monday and it's movie time once again
yep now as we told you guys on Friday we
are working through several movies that
zanada sent to us so thank you very much
zanada who is here this is this is movie
number two right here sent to us on
Blu-ray this is yeah The Departed the
Departed this is a great flick this is a
really good flick all St I had forgotten
one how [__] great this movie is
because I hadn't seen it in a long time
and I also forgot how [__] old this
movie is I forgot that it was like from
2006 yeah I'd never seen it and um so
Martin scorsi flick everything he's made
I've seen that I've seen is is good and
this one does not fail to disappoint it
does not fail to uh yeah this one does
not disappoint yeah um it it does not
fail to live up to my high standards uh
it's uh it's a cool flick real cool
there's a lot to watch i' probably it's
a long movie there's a lot of material
there a lot of little stories going and
subplots and stuff or you know shit's
going on and you're seeing it from
you're trying to see it from the the
Viewpoint of like three or four
different characters that don't some of
them don't know about each other it's
pretty good not real complicated though
in terms of plot it's just kind of the
structure is a little weird uh for me uh
I'd had to see it again though uh it was
gota but like a lot of his gangster
movies are like this yeah and
um it's uh takes place in Boston and
it's funny because it it mentions a lot
of places where I lived yeah Somerville
Medford he mentions Brockton yeah
[__] uh we got a our friend sha who's
been on the show from Brockton and uh
talk about you know the East and [__]
and [__] the uh the Burrows around
Boston and it's pretty true to life and
uh they shot a lot of it there although
some of the interiors and stuff I think
they had to shoot in New York City I've
told because it was cheaper told it a
couple times on other shows when I was
living on Winter Hill I lived at the top
of Winter Hill at a in a four story five
I think it might have been a fivestory
apartment
building it was pretty old and across
the street was a mysterious candy shop
that was never open and I was coming
home from the club one time and the
whole Road had been blocked off by
mysterious [__] and damn
suits you know what I mean they let me
park but they were watching me and they
were
taking um [__] filing cabinets out of
there using a dolly and loading them
into a truck I know how to [__] do
security being exmilitary but they not
sus in the least they were not they and
[__] I was walking towards a dude and
I was slowing down that main [__]
security the guy was on on my standing
on the sidewalk and he just GED RS and
I'm like okay all right something's up
so I just kept walking though cuz I had
to go home man not watching anything and
that was uh the Winter Hill Gang Whitey
buer and his guys which is what sort of
loosely what this is based on but it's I
this isn't based on that realistically
necessarily because this is actually I I
mean I'm sure most people that are
Martin Scorsese fans know this but this
is actually sort of a loose remake of a
Hong Kong action film called infernal
Affairs which came out in
2002 and that one like it follows the
plot kind of Co closely like in the
sense of you know uh one person is like
a rat in the police department and one
person is a rat in the gangster people
so it's kind of like that so it's kind
of similar but they did their own thing
by making it uh based on the winterhill
gang and specifically the character of
Frank costell who's played by Jack
Nichols in the movie is Loosely based on
Whitey Bulger yeah who was also who was
also FBI I saw those guys I saw where
one of their places was I checked on
Google Earth recently after I talked
about it on a show about guess about
about a year and a half ago we were
living here when I talked about it last
and that that candy store is not there
anymore it's been torn down there's a
house there now but that was them and I
wouldn't know I didn't know [__]
Whitey buer I you could have show to me
I wouldn't know they were just D skevy
dudes and Suits
smiling looking at me like I knew who
they were I don't know who you are dude
you're just I just some kind of
gangsters you know well you know but uh
if he was there he would have been over
there in that candy shop [__] loading
them files up or watching there was guys
[__] on the watching it there was
guys all all different ages you know 30
plus there was those guys that was them
though said something to my my neighbor
I said there was dudes he go oh yeah
that's probably the Winter Hill Gang
yeah well they were very they were very
famous Boston and that was on Winter
Hill the very top of it that's where I
Liv Danny rling said some scenes in this
film with Nicholson gave off the Joker
Vibes which is awesome yeah like when he
asked who let this Ira [__] in
here yeah the thing about Jack Nicholson
I think really this movie seems to have
been I mean it won best picture it won
best director it won best editing it won
best uh adapted
screenplay um you know with the Oscars
or whatever and um I think this was
actually the first this is the first
time that Martin scors won a Best
Director Oscar which blows my mind a
little bit um so a lot of people were
just kind of like oh they're giving him
the Lifetime Achievement Award cuz he's
like so many good movies but he hadn't
won so they're just like okay we're
going to give it to him this year
whatever but this also won best picture
so but the thing about it is that really
the only criticism of this movie that
I've seen is that some people thought
Jack Nicholson was a little bit too over
the top um you know and Danny said well
his Boston accent wasn't that good it
wasn't but um you know he probably
should have just talked in his regular
voice and no one would have thought
anything about it but you know let let
the Boston people do the Boston accents
like don't try to do an accent if you
can't really do it you know what I mean
but honestly it didn't really I think it
I think Jack Nicholson's um performance
I think that made him scarier and
actually Leonardo DiCaprio said that too
because he's like Jack
Nicholson he
largely um helped construct that
character because in the original script
he wasn't as fleshed out and Jack
Nicholson I think didn't originally want
to do the movie unless they let him put
his own spin on the character so they
said that he could and so he kind of
went his own way with it and he wanted
him to come across like more as like
just a crazy psychopath you know what I
mean and he sexed up the character a lot
because he's just like always talking
about you know what I mean he's always
like he's like real crass and he's
always talking about [__] all these
chicks and stuff like that one great
scene where he's double dating one
girlfriend he has a white one and he's
got a black one and he shows him back at
back at the pad he takes a whole hand
full of cocaine throws it on the white
one he says go ahead and get
it it's like yeah all right so that I
don't think any of that was in the
original script like that was [__] that
he wanted to add but like I said it's
and Leonardo DiCaprio said that it was
specifically really good for him as an
actor because he's like I never was
entirely sure what Jack Nicholson was
going to do so you'd be on your toes
yeah and well and he was saying since
Leonardo DiCaprio's character in this
Billy corg um what was it not Billy
Corgan the dude from [__] but you
know what I mean Billy cosan that's what
I was going to say I was like not
smashing pumkins guy um Billy kasan was
that his whole thing was he's spoiler
alert um you know he's a cop but he's
infiltrated you know this gang he's a
mole he's a mole and so he's terrified
like from day to day that he's going to
get found out and like [__] shot in
the face or tortured or whatever so it's
like that really comes across like in
all of the scenes with him and Jack
Nicholson where we had hearded Capri
sitting there going what is this
[__] going to do you know what I
mean so I think those are really good um
you know the scenes between them are
really good like really tense because of
that you know it's like a jack Nason
movie but it's also like a Leonardo
DiCaprio movie and it's almost like a
Mark Wahlberg movie it's it's an
All-Star cast I love Mark Wahlberg's
character in this it too yeah like Mark
Wahlberg and I've said this before I
love Mark Wahlberg okay it's like I'm
not [__] on movies I'm not [__]
on him he but he he doesn't have a lot
of range as an actor but that's okay I
mean if you're an actor play your
strengths right and like some actors are
just real real good at like a narrow
window of characters whereas some actors
can just play anything and are
believable he's kind of more of a narrow
window guy but when he's really really
good he's really good I mean look for
you know when he was in Boogie Nights
and stuff he was [__] fantastic in
that just got to cast him right yeah and
actually even though this was a little
bit of a different character than what
he would normally play because I think
he usually is best when he plays kind of
dumb people that are inway over their
heads like you know as in Boogie kns as
in pain and game like he's really good
at that type of character but in this
one I don't know I really liked him in
it he just played like a
complete bastard he's a dick like it he
was a cop yeah and he was a good cop
yeah um but maybe although there are
some theories that he might have been a
mole to but I don't think I buy that he
was a dick but you know if you ever did
any time in the service in in in like
combat arms units everybody's a dick
it's it being a dick is a Pastime and he
was a dick in a funny way yeah and he's
being a dick to his boss and his boss
being a dick back talking about who
[__] whose wife and just [__] like
that that's kind and their moms and
stuff and their mom that's right out of
the army [__] hilarious hilarious
yeah nobody takes it personally it's all
fun and games it's mental wrestling yeah
and uh to have real thick skin and
nothing affects you that's where
Scientology got that when Scientology
constantly [__] with their cult
members you know what I mean and to get
a reaction and if you have an if you
have an emotional reaction then you're
weak that they elron hubber got that
from the service the Navy was like that
so
but uh they show there's a scene where
Mark Wahlberg and his boss who and he
was the boss was the dude that played uh
it was Martin Sheen Martin Sheen that's
right he was in also the dude that
played Drake in Aliens the machine
gunner you know one got killed [__]
he's in it yeah uh everybody's in this
[__] I'm in this movie maybe I mean I
could yeah I was in it but you didn't
see me I was in the back I was in the
back I was also in this movie everyone I
was the one that you guys were all in
this movie too you don't even know you
were in this movie but you were
Ray Windstone was in I love Ray
Windstone although again I kind of wish
cuz he's British I kind of wish that he
had just talked in his regular British
accent rather than trying to do an
American accent because it came across a
little weird but he doesn't talk a lot
in it so it wasn't really that big of a
deal yeah another thing is that they
Point what's cool about this is that
they pointed out some history about uh
about the uh Boston Police
Force uh Boston State excuse me
massachusett State Police that might
have been Boston PD too Boston PD that I
think they were the ones it was their
uniform that inspired the SS police
uniform there were some
German um diplomats they went to Boston
and they saw that Boston cop uniform
they man that's badass later on they're
Contracting like Hugo Boss to make a
black reproduction make some [__] like
that and that was so a lot of times you
know people [__] think that the Nazis
invented this weird [__] no they were
copying most of the time and they got
that they got that uniform signed from
the Boston police well it's funny
because Tom came in and he said that
like he's like oh you know and and I did
know that actually but then I was like
oh you missed it you were in the
bathroom like very early on in the movie
like somebody makes a joke about that
like wait look at you like dress like
you're about to invade Poland or
something like that cuz I said so they
already acknowledged they already
acknowledged that and made a joke about
it which I uh very much appreciated they
have some of the best police uniforms or
dress uniforms [__] fantastic it's
got lapels on it and [__] it's real
practical just looks real serious real
Ser the thing was this movie it wasn't I
mean it came out in 2006 it wasn't
supposed to be set in 2006 though was it
or was it no I don't well no because
yeah they did have 2006 era flip phones
flip phones I was wondering because
because that's what I thought I was like
this isn't supposed to be like in the
past or anything like that cuz I thought
I read somewhere that it was supposed to
be like years before I'm using modern
guns yeah I'm like that can't be right
because they they all had flip phones
and stuff like you would have in 2006 so
yeah it's [__] funny
man Jack Nicholson's character just uses
racial slurs all the time it doesn't
matter what race you are he's going to
slur it he's there talking to the
Chinese and he said no Ticky no laundry
just I just [__] with him man it's
[__] funny funny as [__] he's just
real crass yeah he's real [__] crass
and he's he's trying to take it to an
art form but he's like volatile and like
I said I think that that's kind of what
made his character scary yeah is because
you never entirely knew like what he was
how he was going to react to [__] or
like what he was going to do exactly
yeah cuz he's joking around doing all
this [__] and crazy then he'll snap
you're not sure whether or not he's
really mad if he's [__] with you yeah
but see I mean that I would think that
people that ran big organizations like
that it would behoove them to kind of
act like that because you always like
[__] terrified to like kind of
terrified to like do anything to cross
them because you never knew if they were
going to like be okay with it or if they
were just going to like you know blow
out your kneecaps or whatever there were
a lot of good scenes though where Leo
DiCaprio character is tell him you know
eventually one of your guys is going to
kill you and take your place he goes
yeah I know you know because that's just
the way it is it organized crime soon as
you get weak they're going to [__]
kill you and he's he was trying to I
don't remember exactly what he was
trying to do he trying to break him down
a little bit he he was he didn't want to
get discovered as being a [__]
undercover Poli rat as being the rat so
he did what he could to put pressure on
his own boss you know they're going to
come and get you but I ain't the rat
though you don't need to be worried
about the rat you wor the people that
trying to kill did a good job of I don't
want to be you but I really think and
Zan said Matt Damon is actually really
good in this movie and I'm not a a Matt
Damon fan oh he's good he was good in
this I think because this role kind of
played to his strengths he was
playing someone who was a bad guy he was
in with the gangsters like he was Frank
Costello's contact but he was pretending
to be this upstanding cop he was like
real high up in the police because he
was a plant like they had planted him
there
so you know he would get all these
promotions and he was just like
supposedly his big stickler and buy the
book like he was he kind of came across
like a goody two shoes I don't know if
you caught this but they also implied
that he was impotent did you get that oh
they did it to who to uh to Matt Damon
character Sullivan yeah well I took it
as that he he had a failure to perform
with that one chick CU he was under all
that [__] stress about getting caught
by this be maybe
he seemed less concerned about getting
but see that's what I thought was so
cool because the two characters
obviously are were set up to be mirror
images of each other and that's why the
movie the editing in This Is Amazing by
the way I think that um thma scoon
mocker I think is or schoon maker I
can't remember how you pronounce it but
she edits most of his movies or all of
his movies is it I can't remember but
she definitely added this one I think
she want an Oscar for this but um I
really like and I think Danny pointed
out earlier he's like I think some
people that didn't that couldn't follow
this movie was because of the editing
it's a little kinetic but it kind of
cuts back and forth between the two of
them without really stopping to breathe
um and it's a long movie but it doesn't
to me it didn't it doesn't seem long
like because there's always something
happening and it's like always moving on
along at a good clip and you get like so
immersed in the character and there's so
much suspense over you know if they're
going to get caught and all this other
kind of [__] and so even even though I
think that Matt Damon's character and
Leonardo DiCaprio's character are set up
as mirror images of each other but see
Leonardo
DiCaprio who is a good guy he's a cop
now he's able to infiltrate the reason
that he was chosen to Infiltrate The
Gangs was because his family were all
gangsters they were all with the crime
family particularly his uncle so he
would have an inn like they knew his
family and they would just assume and
they made him go to jail and all this
other kind of stuff so he would look
legit these are all Irish American gangs
yeah it's it's Irish mob yeah it's not
Italian yeah there Italian mob is not
really in this there's like one scene
with them in it but that's about it like
they mentioned them a couple times but
that's about it this is Irish mob and so
but he is because he's a good guy he is
way more worried about getting caught
than Matt Damon's character is cuz I
feel like Matt Damon and maybe you're
right maybe the whole thing about him
and and it was subtle like the way that
they kind of implied like him being
impotent and everything like that but
it's like maybe that was kind of of just
saying that was his one little crack
like one little weakness because other
than that he came across as like pretty
cool and smooth you know what I mean
like he had his [__] together because I
feel like maybe he had less to fear
maybe yeah I mean because I don't think
based on what the girl had said and my
knowledge of the [__] subject itself
I don't think he was habitually that
way he was just having a problem at that
time well they did kind of I was
watching like a break down of it and
they were kind of saying that that maybe
they were kind of contrasting his
character as being sort of
asexual against Jack Nicholson's
character being like being like like
hypersexual well they might have been
just trying to say this guy's
hypersexual because of his confidence
level and he just feels indestructible
you know what I mean he said he didn't
he because that character that played by
jck Nicholson was saying that he could
do all this [__] he could get [__]
unlimited [__] and he didn't even want
it anymore he really didn't care well he
said he didn't need it he just he just
liked it he just liked it he so he was
under wasn't under any pressure the Matt
Damon character he was under pressure
he's [__] working and he's [__]
fearing for his life yeah so I think
they were just trying to say that he
didn't quite have any the confidence he
wasn't comfortable in in the environment
but as I said fear of fear of failure
yeah but he came across as much more
together than Leonardo DiCaprio's
character who was clearly like losing
his [__] yeah because he was like
terrified that he was going to get found
out because he well because he was
thrust into a situation where he had to
do [__] like murder people and [__] and
they he couldn't say anything right you
know had to kill innocent people and
stuff like that and he couldn't say
anything or he'd get caught so it was
really starting to [__] him up and
that's why he started going to you know
Vera forz character the psychiatrist um
in the original movie I haven't seen the
original movie actually the original
movie spawned I believe two sequels a
prequel and a TV series that's how
popular it was in China um so but in the
original movie I think that there were
two separate character like two separate
female characters like one that was the
psychiatrist and then one another love
interest person for like the other but
in this movie they combined both of them
into a single character which I think
was I want to say that was maybe
slightly unbelievable that she would end
up you know essentially again spoiler
alert like sleeping with both of them
yeah you know what I mean but I guess
it's what I I don't know it didn't
really bother me while I was watching it
but then like afterward I was just kind
of like well would that really happen
I'm nervous but like I said it's just a
movie so I wasn't really worried about
it but yeah but that's why because
originally in the original movie that
was two separate characters and they
just combined it into one character I
like this one better than the Jimmy Hoff
movie the Irishman yeah I think I did
too I really liked the Irishman this one
was better but I think this one was
better I do definitely think this do
look better well because this one had um
I guess because this one is like a
fictional story yes it's sort of loosely
the charact some of the characters are
based on real people but it's a it's a
fictional story um but so I think they
had more leeway whereas the Irishman was
kind of based on real [__] so they you
know you're kind of constrained because
you can't go too far you can't go too
crazy you know what I mean um but this
one you could kind of be creative with
it and [__] like that I think this one
too had a lot more tension and a lot
more
suspense because you really did
particularly for leono Leonardo
DiCaprio's character because you really
started like over the course of the
movie you really started like freaking
out for him like you cuz he was losing
it like he was really scared that he was
going to get killed and and they and as
you know they as the mob started
thinking hey there was a rat in here and
they Maybe started suspecting it was him
and he was trying to get them to think
think that it wasn't him and all this
other kind of crap it was just kind of
like you really start to like feel for
him I didn't feel as much for Matt
Damon's character because like I said he
didn't seem he might have been [__] up
too I'm sure he was but I think he had
more recourse if something went sideways
because look if they found out that he
was the rat you know he could just call
up Costello and be like hey get me the
[__] out of this because you know there
was corruption everywhere they even find
out at the end of the movie that there
was another rat other than him like in
the another gangster like in the police
department so it's like he had a way out
he wouldn't necessarily go to jail or
anything like that because look at all
the [__] Costello did and he was still
walking around free and he was also they
found out later in FBI informant yeah
Zan was saying that WHYY buer was an F
that's what I mean that's yeah so they
base that on him like he was also thing
is is buer was more than
that he was actually doing things like
smuggling weapons namely namely the ar18
or the ar18 the ArmaLite which is like
the M16 part two he was smuggling those
to the
IRA and seemingly the FBI knew about it
and seemingly the CIA may have put him
up to
it which I don't understand how that
would work out why they would want that
but I think buer was not just an
informant I think he was an
operative now one of the dudes that
ended up being like
uh he was a a big powerful da in
Massachusetts he was a friend of his and
he ended up being becoming a Fed in the
Justice Department I forgot which one it
was Whitey buer was a friend of his and
he was like in charge of the [__]
justice department for a while and they
were like personal
friends evidently doing gangster [__] or
doing different sides
of special intelligence operations or
something I think I think buer was more
kind of like an intelligence
mercenary for CIA we should probably do
a show about him one of these days he
was kind of he wasn't just a gagster he
was more than that and I also seem to
remember that he was
suspected in some serial killer type
[__] yeah torturing and killing some
women sexually I don't know well there
was one in particular that I remember
that woman that they found um out on
that woman that they thought was an
extra in Jaws yeah Lady of the dunes
yeah yeah did they ever identify her I
have to look that up again but yeah um
he was suspected in that but I don't
think they ever proved that he was
involved but he was one of the suspects
for kind of out of character for a guy
like that but there's no
telling usually a serial killer that's
all he is that's all he's going to do
yeah they're not usually gangsters on
the side yeah they're not gangsters on
the side I mean it's not
impossible usually unusual usually
gangsters have good have good
relationship with women
uh they don't they're
not they're not they're not [__] you
know they don't kill women unless
there's a reason you know I usually some
kind of business you
know so uh they tend to be you
know popular with women just
say yeah but um hold on yeah mango says
the original film this was based on
infernal Affairs is really worth
watching yeah I've seen clips of it it
does look really good and I probably
should get around to it one of these
days like I said they actually made it
into a Trilogy and I think they also
made a prequel of it as well but they
changed I don't know if they changed a
great deal but the idea of it is similar
Danny says the theater dildo scene was
funny as [__] that was really good that
whole yeah that whole theater scene was
like really funny Jack yeah Jack
Nicholson with the [__] he had a
black dildo too like
big pretend like he was jerking it w
waving it in Matt Damon's face that was
pretty awesome yeah he he was he was uh
sexually experimental [__] he was
open he didn't he he thought he thought
all that [__] was funny yeah yeah um
yeah Zan said let me see uh this movie
is not very violent for a gangster flick
it does have only at the end bursts of
violence yeah but it's not there were a
couple scenes that were kind of like
like the one where he where he was um
where Le DiCaprio was like smashing in
that that um Italian mobster's face with
the pole or whatever like in the
convenience story that was kind of
[__] up well it's not really called
for in the story VI isn't always called
for it's funny too because this is one
it's not the it's not the top Echelon
movie but it's one of the movies that
uses [__] more than any other movie yeah
which is hilarious because when I was
watch I kind of knew that going in
because I had heard that here and there
but while we were watching it it didn't
occur to to me that anybody was saying
it any more than normal I guess because
we swear so much it doesn't really
register I guess now that I guess now
more I think about it this is the jack
NASA
movie it's got It's got [__] great
Supporting Cast but he is kind of the
the centerpiece of this
movie yeah kind of like somebody said
earlier I think it might have been
zanada said that this might have been
Jack Nicholson's last great role he he
might have retired not too long after
this you don't see him in stuff that
much anymore but you know he's getting
older and everything like that but I
he's way old now yeah he's super old
yeah now he he was basically old in The
Shining well yeah he's one of those
dudes that's kind of always looked like
an old man cuz if you see him even like
back in the Roger Corman movie which he
was in that was called The Terror I
think and when and he was in um the
original Little Shop of Horrors from
the' 60s MH and if you see him in that
um like he's clearly younger but he's
still it's the receding hairline is why
it just made him look younger or made
him look older rather One Flew Over this
Cuckoo's Nest I still think one of his
best I love that [__] movie book is
great too if you've never read it but um
but yeah so I don't think Jack Nicholson
I guess I don't know if he was the first
choice for that role I think that well
they wanted dairo but I don't think they
wanted dairo for that role I think they
wanted him for the Martin Sheen role
yeah but he turned it down cuz he was
doing he was directing another movie and
he didn't want to do it now initially
Brad Pit amazingly was the guy that
secured the rights to the Chinese movie
cuz he wanted to do a b CU he has a
production company too I think it's
called Plan B and he was initially going
to play the Matt Damon character yeah
but then when they cast DiCaprio he was
like uh he's like I think somebody
younger should play the Sullivan role
because he's like I want them to be more
similar and age and at that point Brad
Pit was about 10 or 11 years older than
Leonardo DiCaprio yeah um so they said
we want somebody you know well Brad Pit
said that he said I'll just produce it
I'm not going to be in it CU I'm too old
so which I thought was pretty cool that
he said that he's like I want somebody
that's closer to to Leonardo Di caprio's
age so they got Matt Damon and I think
they were only like four years apart
because they wanted like I said the the
whole point of the characters is that
they're supposed to be mirror images of
one another like Martin Scorsese is
making a point about and he even makes
this like pretty overtly in the movie
about it doesn't really matter what side
of the law you're on like there's not
really much difference you know what I'm
saying this the whole moral gray area
yeah you you know so one of them being a
good guy pretending to be a bad guy and
the other one bad guy pretending to be a
good guy and then they're trying to like
find each other out so they wanted them
to be similar looking and similar in age
I never really understood the uh the
Robert dairo thing he had some great
roles I really liked him in uh taxi
driver I thought he was actually crazy
and and and menacing in that one I don't
think we've actually reviewed taxi
driver have we holy [__] that one I was
kind of like yeah okay I I see what
people kind of see in in him he's
[__] psycho he kind of pulls it off
and then he becomes in a weird way a
hero at the end of that one uh kind of a
weird weird movie I liked it I haven't
seen it in a long time yeah it's been a
while since I've seen I remember
thinking that was his best one now they
had the other one wasn't he in Good
Fellas I thought he was great in Good
Fellas and he was good in I think Casino
I think was the other one I [__] we
just reviewed that one not too long ago
actually but he always kind
of oh and Cape Fear Ed to point out yeah
he's [__] great in [__] great in K
he's great in that that's I mean that's
a remake but still yeah it's a great REM
forgot about that one but yeah he's very
powerful in in Kate fear the way he
comes off but there's something about
like when he's playing a rle like
something out of cap fear and something
like out a taxi driver even though he's
much harder in cap fear he comes off as
being more physically
threatening and he's not a big guy you
know I think he's my size I think he
might be about five six and he's not
real jacked or anything it's something
about his face in his
delivery he made kind of when he was
doing a gangster role he played more of
an executive level gangster not so much
you know torpedo type guy yeah that was
a little more
believable but I don't really understand
the attraction all the time you know to
uh he's well like a lot of actors he's
good in certain types of roles and not
so good in others I mean I've liked him
Zan points out dairo was um uh or no
mango points out that uh that he was
really great as Lucifer in Angel Heart
uh which I love that movie and I think
for that role I think it's really
underrated but like he played like the
devil essentially yeah he got fat for
that role but that is also a good movie
yeah he's eating the higher boiled eggs
that's pretty good um uh Danny says I
just got the changeling on DVD and it's
quite obvious the film The Others was a
little bit inspired by that film oh big
time we still haven't reviewed the
others but I [__] I [__] love the
others yeah real good um not and it's
not the one about the twin boys that's
the other the others was a ghost story
with Nicole Kidman that came out seen
one the one about the twin boys was
[__] creepy too man back in the 70s
oh that book is fantastic also Thomas
Tron if you've never read the book the
book is also called the others Thomas
Tron also read another book called
Harvest home which for real is one of
the scariest things I've ever read it
was so [__] Insidious it was a folk
horror it's [__] great they made like
a TV movie version of it but it wasn't
really that good but the book is [__]
fantastic the book scared the [__]
crap out of me um but yeah I think he
used to be an actor he was in Thomas
Tron he was in some movies back in the
50s I think he might have been in I
married a monster from Outer Space if
I'm remembering that correctly um he
played the alien but he was actually an
author I don't think he wrote a [__] ton
of books but I read the others and I
read uh Harvest home and those two are
[__] fantastic Harvest Home is one of
my favorite horror novels of all time I
wish they'd make a good movie of it but
they still haven't so far um but yeah
mango says I watched Witches of Eastwick
the other week he steals that movie Jack
Nicholson by the way yeah Jack Nicholson
again he plays The Devil in that movie I
kind of love that movie um it's I just
have like a soft spot for it it's a lot
different than the book the book was by
John Updike and I read the book several
times there's a whole other character
named Jenny in the book that the older
witches kill because she's younger and
prettier than them and he's like wanting
to marry her um so they took all of that
out of the movie I guess because they
wanted because they wanted to make them
more sympathetic I suppose um but yeah
in the book they were a lot uh more
eviler but I think I liked the movie
slightly better just the movie was more
light-hearted the book was like a lot
more like a super like dark comedy no
doubt man Nicholson's a legend oh yeah I
mean no doubt did a great Joker too well
yeah and I don't think he he's not as
over the top as the Joker in this movie
there's some but you can tell he's kind
of channeling of that a little bit just
in the sense of him being like super
unpredictable yeah but I think that
comes across like I said I think the
only criticism of this movie that I ever
saw because this is a pretty universally
Beloved movie I feel like not
universally cuz nothing is but you know
what I mean like 99% of people like
really love this movie but that's really
the only like criticism I saw that
people were like well I thought Jack NS
was a little bit over the top you know
the scene where he's you know talking to
uh Leonardo dicapri over breakfast and
he's just sitting there with the severed
hand yeah like in the bag just very
calmly taking the wedding ring off it
and like [__] like that I don't know I
thought that was [__] hilarious was
great in Mars Attacks too people he has
two roles in that one I can remember he
was good in that he played the president
and the guy trying to buy the casino mhm
yeah you made me laugh and I spit my rum
out
yeah now I get I got to here hand me
that hand me that thing over there I
can't quite reach it yeah he made me
laugh and I was just like spit my rum
out see that's what happened I'm getting
my [__] all wet getting my computer all
wet getting some rum and coke on there
yeah Z said I [__] Lov Mars Attacks
yeah it's not I mean Mars Attacks is
[__] man I I love that [__] movie I
love that you could watch that many
times you can watch it but you never get
bored with that one I mean there's just
so much going on everybody's a
stereotype fine everybody's a stereotype
and everybody believes in some [__] that
isn't true the only people that are
actually true and accurate in the movie
are the Martians and the Martians don't
give a [__] man well that's what's so
great about the movie is that the humans
in it are like not sympathetic at all so
you're just kind of like the you know
the everybody's dumb yeah like the
aliens get there and you're just kind of
like yeah just wipe them all out it's
fine you know what I mean which I think
is like really funny so um Zan wanted to
know what you thought about the ending
of the departed where pretty much
everyone gets shot spoiler alert much
everybody kills each other I had
forgotten well cuz like I said I saw
this movie but a very long time ago so I
don't remember anything that happened in
it so I'm watching it and like the end
part where you know spoiler alert
Leonardo DiCaprio comes out the [__]
elevator and just gets [__] shot in
the head I was like what I forgot all
about holy [__] like everybody gets
[__] shot and Matt Damon shows up and
go in faceing his G his [__] face was
[__] a gun he oh okay all right then
a second you think he's not going to get
shot but d goes no
Shew yeah Matt Damon all good well
because for a while you think oh Matt
Damon who was again the gangster
character that was embedded in the cops
but everybody but nobody suspected
really that he was the rat so it's like
he that [__] he's going to get
away with everything but then no Mark
Wahlberg is there in the apartment he
says nay I am going to wipe your ass out
I guess it was because like I said
there's a lot of theory swirling about
this some people say oh it's because
Mark Wahlberg's character whose name was
um dnam ding dnam something like that um
that he was also a rat I don't believe
that I think he just did that because um
Matt Damon's character got Queen in
Martin Sheen's character killed by
essent like throwing him under the bus I
think he's the rat like follow him and
then he also like so all the cops
followed him and then he also called
Costello's gang and said where he was
going to be and they threw him off a
[__] roof right so he got Queen and
killed and you know Mark Wahlberg was
like really as much of an [__] as he
was he was very very loyal to his boss
who was Queen in so I think he was mad
when he found out that Matt Damon had
thrown Queen in under the bus and gotten
him killed and so he's like I'm going to
take this [__] Out and because
I'm a cop I'm going to get away with it
now he was on administrative leave I
believe he didn't get fired did he I
think he just got two weeks
suspension so I don't know how he's
going to explain that the one thing they
didn't wrap up I mean I'm just going to
kind of assume but but you know Leonardo
DiCaprio's character gets killed too
right now and then you think Matt
Damon's is going to get away with it but
then he does it like he gets shot also
and then Frank Costello Jack Nicholson's
character he's also got shot because
Matt Damon shot him because I'm thinking
that Matt Damon was like I'm gonna take
over this [__] well I think he was mad
too because he found out that Jack
Nicholson was a FBI informant so he's
like well I'm just going to take over
your whole outfit but that didn't work
out you know so all of that happens and
then prior to Leonardo de Rio getting
killed he gives Vera Fara charact the
ver Fara character the psychiatrist he
gives her an envelope and says only open
this if something bad happens to me like
if I get killed or if I call you and
tell you to open it but they never tell
you what was in there so I presume it
was evidence against Matt Damon because
he did send some of the tapes and [__]
like that to her that was why she broke
up with him right but I assume that she
that he had like more solid evidence
it's like hey if something happens to me
like give this to the proper authorities
so that even if Matt Damon is dead by
that point then nobody will think he's
like Lil Miss Perfect like [__]
awesome cop or anything like that
they're going to know he was a gangster
plant this whole time so I'm assuming
that's what it was but they never really
wrapped that up so I don't know but I'm
assuming that's what it was speaking of
gangsters me and
Jen we're getting the gangster car I'm
looking at two [__] Cadillacs man
one's a 2009 [__]
I STS it looks mint [__] doesn't have
all it's a cool looking car actually man
it's [__] mint all right and it's
it's it's
got 150,000 miles on it but you can get
a lot of miles on them I looked under
the hood this shit's so [__] clean
it's not even funny it's in my price
range I can probably get it for 65 I
think then the other one I want to look
at tomorrow I've been talking to the to
the lock that has it it's a 2014 it's
white white leather interior the first
one is red the first one was yeah
burgundy red with a cream colored
leather interior it's pretty Swanky oh
yeah it looks brand new actually looks
brand new yeah we went that on Saturday
and like sat in it and talked to they
want to sell it to me because I can I
can do it cash and then the white one is
the about the same price they're
starting off at eight but I know I can
get a couple Grand off that well and if
we we use my car a tra we could maybe
get cash purchase I could get get a
better deal on 2014 fully [__] loaded
got the sunroof [__] Deluxe
navigation package all the [__]
internet Bluetooth connections and just
everything the other one was a little
bit more of a base model I think I
wasn't able to turn it on so I didn't
could the screen didn't come up but
they're just [__] I was doing
research I was thinking man I bet you
repairs are a lot on these things it
wouldn't look to see how much an
alternator cost it wasn't any more than
a good
Ford the batteries were expensive
because it's it runs a big battery it's
a $300 battery two well for a good one
about 300 but most of the parts seem to
be on par with other cars and they have
a pretty good reliability rating so as
long as they're not
thrashed you know you can get 300,000
miles on one of those things you take
care of
it yeah go tomorrow and look at that
[__] I'm going go look at the white
we've looked at the red one we went last
Saturday because it's the car lot that
we that we saw it at is on the way to
Ichiban the Chinese buffet saw that
thing sitting in there for so we we kept
seeing it and I was just kind that looks
like a nice car and it looks like it's
not that it's not that expensive sticker
on the window said seven uh 7995 7995 on
it I'm going like I can get that turned
out that was one of the only ones that
they could sell for cash most of the
other ones you could you had to finance
those lots make money off selling
financing package not cars that's not
what profit is but that was one that
they sell for cash because I'm gonna
just pay for it buy it out right and uh
the thing is is for the same price I can
get a 2014 with only 140,000 M and white
and here in Florida red does not last
long that's the only thing I I prefer a
red car yeah but we don't really have
room in the garage to park it yeah I got
motorcycles in there and another car
yeah so there's other [__] in there so
it's like we don't really have room to
park it so it's like if you park a red
car out on your driveway yeah it's going
to like um that you're going to have a
bad time that's all thing so it's not
the Red's not going to last long white
lasts a lot better what I'll do is I'll
get a cover cuz we don't drive all that
often that's a good idea and I'll just
put it in the trunk yeah and uh just
cover the car and that that saves a lot
of problems too because we've had some
break-ins because they don't have the
guards at the gates anymore they got
Gates but they're don't tell everyone
that what's that don't tell everyone
that all these people all these people
in the com I got that D if I hear that
alarm coming I'll be coming with an
AR-15 I I'll CCH Cut You Down and then
just bring you in the house yeah and
then cut you up and make soup out of you
yeah we don't call the cops around here
this is like in Florida feed you to the
cat this is Florida this is a rich
neighborhood we don't call the cops okay
and it's kind of rural too so yeah right
yeah no no one would hear anything yeah
they don't care they're shooting all the
they're shooting all the time in here
they're [__] shooting AR-15s and AKs
and [__] sniper rifles once heard
well that was at the old house heard
somebody shooting a suppressed
submachine gun yeah cuz all that's legal
here if you got the right licensing and
you can usually hear it from like cuz
there's shooting ranges and [__] like
that all around here like Woods where
you can shoot and like you can hear it
from here yeah I ain't scared and I I I
understand all the investigative
techniques and I know everything about
response time and I've trained cops and
soldiers and [__] like that I'm not
scared you come
[__] come steal from me you're taking
your life in your hands and probably
your family's life's in your hands
because I'm gonna go through your wallet
find out where you came from well don't
don't bang the family they
didn't although I kept saying we did
have some even though this is kind this
is like a nice neighborhood we did have
some car break-ins in this neighbor kids
though it was just a bunch of teenagers
though and honestly I'm just kind of
like that's the one nice thing about me
having like a super shitty car I'm just
like they don't want that [__] I'm like
even if you did like take it it's
insured in my experience in my
experience if it's covered they just
pass it right because like they don't
see it they can't see it and they can't
they don't want to take the cover off it
because really obvious step like people
be like hey what the [__] are you kids
doing taking a alarm the alarm will
sound right and you know this house
overwatches the drive way I got four
[__] windows I can pop out no one two
three four windows I can pop out of yeah
you can see the driveway from these
windows and from my dressing room
windows next door like you can see right
out on the driveway yeah and the windows
over there in the gym you can also see
the front yard on the driveway so you
know um let's let's see they were
talking about uh they were talking about
Mars Attacks and then yeah Zan said Matt
Damon's character oh and I didn't even
notice this Zan says Matt Damon's
character as a kid was holding groceries
at the beginning because remember Frank
costell was like getting him into the
thing and then he's holding them at the
end like when he gets shot I'm just like
oh yeah I didn't even realize
that in case you all didn't know Mars
Attacks the visuals and a lot of the
ideas and some of the scenes came out of
a 1950s uh collector's card set for kids
I think it might have been called Mars
Attacks and man you're [__] spooky I
don't think it was related to a
particular like um intellectual property
at the time they were just completely
made up yeah completely made up just
based on yeah like trading currs you
like you got with gum and [__] look at
Mars Attacks trading cards here yeah
they're cool [__] spooky man [__]
little girl in bed with her cat and a
[__] Martian coming in and frying
both of them the cats catching on fire
and the girls screaming and [__] that
was all post World War II [__] man those
dudes were hardcore back then they're
[__] burning whole the Martians burning
whole [__] herds of cattle which they
show that in the movie yeah that was in
the movie that was that was right from
the card yeah and they pretty muchart
they pretty much look just like they did
in the cards pretty much yeah cuz Tim
Burton really liked those yeah cards
they're real Grim and yeah very very
Grim so he actually bur kids up
replicated like a lot of the artwork
from those cards like in the movie it
looks like something out of the Japanese
Pacific War a lot of flamethrower
actions except it's ray guns yeah they
did do some gruesome [__] back well cuz
like look at all the EC Comics back then
you know I mean like Tales from the
Crypt and stuff like that they were
pretty like gory eerie and creepy yeah
and like little kids were reading those
yeah I was reading e and I you know it's
like their parents didn't love it but
you know what I mean they that's how
kind of parents do um yeah also Zan said
and I forgotten about this Matt Damon
had deleted his files that said DiCaprio
was a cop before they met on that
rooftop that's right
that's right so that was that so how
would that play out
then because he was able to go in there
and like say he just deleted all record
of him so even if even if his girlfriend
did come out and say Hey you know I have
proof of this and that I don't know
maybe it wouldn't have mattered but he
did like yeah delete his identity pretty
much which kind of like is something
because Leonard DiCaprio his character
like all he wanted was his identity back
because he had been undercover for so
long and he was starting to like lose
his [__] like I said so he was just kind
of he wanted his identity back so I
guess that was significant that Matt DAV
Damon like deleted his identity or at
least like his cop identity you know
what I
mean uh Danny says black CTS Cadillacs
looks like the look like the Batmobile
first gen anyway
yeah mango says I'm gonna have to go
back and rewatch The Departed now I've
got so many new Blu-rays to get through
at the moment yeah I mean yeah I really
I like I said I saw it a long time ago
probably a year or two after it came out
so [__] 15 16 years ago something
like that and I had forgotten almost
everything about it um but I forgot how
[__] good it was like I said I loved
all the acting I loved the editing in
particular I can see why it got an Oscar
actually everything that
um what what are you trying to do making
him a uh oh moderator how you do what
make him a moderator don't touch stuff I
I didn't know what you're were doing
yeah uh it's not working yeah it works
isn't it no it's not it's not working
it's not doing anything normally it's
supposed to work but it doesn't do
anything I'll have to go in later and do
it that I was trying to make you a
moderator yeah it's it's not doing
anything though for whatever reason I
thought I used to have the uh the
dots maybe you can do
it normally I'd be able to do it but
it's not for some reason it's not
working it must be it must be glitching
out must be glitching out there's little
dots there I know that don't get mad at
me yeah it's not I'm telling you it's
not doing anything what is these lines
here does that say anything no that's
this is not okay this is not YouTube all
right I can figure it out okay I'm
telling you it's not doing anything well
part of it is we're down at the bottom
right okay that's if you want to add a
message where did it go see it's not
doing anything that's what I keep
telling you he doesn't believe me here
we go no that's not doing anything
either yeah why is that not working
because it's glitching out that's why
that's what I was trying to I shut okay
shut it and then open it back up no it's
not it's just not working I can do it
later okay just don't don't [__] with
things because I don't I don't know
what's going to happen it's it's just
not working you know it's just not
working this I don't know if it's just
because I need to update this program or
I don't really know what the deal is but
it hasn't really been able it hasn't
really been working you know what I mean
like [__] that's supposed to work it's
not working not all the function have
full functionality yeah that's what I
mean you click on stuff like it's like
hey you can do this thing but you click
on it it doesn't do anything you know so
I'm kind of used to it um let I thought
I used to have the ability here I
thought you did too but I don't know if
it's not there anymore uh yeah zaner
said red cars are statistically more
likely to get pulled over yeah go with
weight well here we only care about does
the color fade and is it hot and yeah
that's why a lot of it's why a lot of
people don't have black cars here just
because you'll you'll die you'll die
Florida's it's like it's like an oven
white cars and silver cars that's what
you want I mean you see other colors too
but you know what I mean those are all
garage kep cars though yeah like I said
we don't really have room in the garage
to put another car I can work something
out though yeah we can maybe can maybe
we can move some stuff around or take
some [__] to get rid of all those damn
shelves yeah and go with a system that
hangs from the wall that might be but I
need something to go into concrete so i'
have to hire some guys to come in here
and do that and they could get rid of
those shelves and free up a lot of space
in there so I could put cars and
motorcycles was in
there yeah Z said I was going to send
you guys Mars Attacks till I saw you had
already reviewed it did it yeah I got
yeah yeah we already have that I'm
pretty sure yeah did we own that own it
yeah I thought we did yeah I got I
thought we
did mango said I heard Burton is
remaking attack of the 50-foot woman not
sure about it myself didn't they remake
attack of the 50-foot woman wasn't Daryl
Hannah in it or is I'm am I high I don't
know I thought they remade that like in
the 80s or the '90s or something
costume's asking you what what you're
using for a program what um OBS OBS yeah
now it I haven't updated it for well not
a long time but I haven't updated the
latest version so I might do that like
tomorrow and then see if it works but
yeah the chat thing like I said
everybody's name has these three little
dots next to it which theoretically when
you press you're supposed to be able to
do something but it doesn't do anything
see even if you do it up there it's like
times that's all you get you don't
there's nothing there so I don't know if
it's just because I haven't updated it
or I don't know what the deal is but
I'll find out like tomorrow I'll update
it tomorrow Oracle said I dye my own
yarn and red is an easy come easygo
color like it takes real easy but it
fades out real quick yeah and it's the
same kind of thing like if you look at
people that put bumper stickers like on
their car if that bumper sticker has you
know like blue and red ink on it the
blue still looks crisp and new and the
red is just like gone yeah it's just
like pink and most red cars here are
pink pretty much yeah
yeah and it doesn't matter how high
quality the paint is just too much
ultrav Violet radiation yeah it just
Fades like pretty much um let's see yeah
Oracle said yeah they did a Daryl Hanner
version okay so I'm not crazy it's like
I could have sworn yeah she said it was
more of a comedy that's what I remember
I don't remember if I saw it but I
remember seeing some [__] about it Daryl
H actually got better looking as she got
older she became kind of a sexier
[__] cougar than she was as a young
girl as a young woman I
thought yeah I can see yeah she kind of
grew into well the thing about Daryl
Hannah was that um yeah I kind of think
she looks she looked better as like a
slightly older woman yeah like she was
pretty when she was younger I'm not
saying that but she was a lot more curvy
when she got older I don't know if she
got implants or what but she was
just she was just sexier when she hit
about 40 do you remember Splash her and
Tom Hanks where she played a where she
played a mermaid yeah like he fell in
love with a mermaid yeah I saw that
movie like at least 400 times it was on
cable all the time that's kind of it was
kind of a cool movie you know what I
mean she played kind of a well she
wasn't an idiot I mean she was just a
mermaid I think she's a bimbo in real
life maybe I've seen interviews with her
she's kind of an airhead oh okay I've
never seen anything like
that I've never seen anything like that
I remember kind of liking splash like I
saids nice but she seems kind of vacant
kind of oh okay you know just one of
those yeah uh Casten Lee says yeah OBS
is pretty user friendly it is yeah I I
really like it and I haven't really had
too much problem with it but like I said
I haven't updated it in a bit and it has
been asking me to update so maybe that's
the problem but we'll see how it goes
I'll update it tomorrow yeah mango said
she looked great with an eye patch and
Kill Bill yeah I mean did we review Kill
Bill no I don't think we have
I actually didn't like it I'm real picky
about I saw I saw in the theater yeah
I'm real picky about his work some of it
I like some of it I don't some of it I
love some of it I don't like just
depends on how what he's doing I really
liked Once Upon a Time in Hollywood I
thought that was perfect that was a
great [__] movie I really like that a
lot I can watch that [__] all day long
yeah I see what you're saying though
like I get I'm he gets too silly and I
don't want to [__] hear
it yeah he does I know what you're
saying I know going down the [__] I
know what you're saying Chinese [__]
Kung Fu theater Route and [__] just
silly [__] well he loves that stuff I'm
like shut the [__] up so I kind of I
well I kind of get that because it's
like that's what he grew up with and he
loves that kind of [__] and he's like
we're just going to do this crazy thing
which I respect that you me and Quinton
went to the same Elementary
School Dominguez Elementary School in
[__] [__] Carson
California he was a few few years older
than me though I remember
him but I thought he might have been the
same age as me but it turns out the
dates couldn't have been right he was a
little bit older than
me then my friend I left I left
Dominguez but my friends stayed the ones
that I kind of grew up with Jim and Mike
North and Jim [__] knew him uh I grew
up with Jim j Jimmy ended up being a
state police officer California no
California Highway Patrol he was a chip
he was a chip officer
and uh he knew Quinton from working at
the video store video rental
store over there where uh El Rancho's
Mexican restaurant used to be on the
corner it's where the old library was
and he was there for a long time and he
was just some weird
dude that rented V that rented your
videos it was like a mom PW video rental
store from what I remember from what
they told me
but uh so I kind of know where he grew
up and he's he's a great director I
don't want to say he's good he's great
it's just that he's sometimes he's on
and sometimes he's
off um I loved Reservoir Dogs I thought
that was a [__] really good play more
than anything else thought that was good
Pulp Fiction I thought was a
masterpiece and I also thought that uh
[__] uh Once Upon a Time in Hollywood
was a masterpiece yeah I love that movie
yeah that's a [__] good movie I
bought you the steelbook didn't I yeah
for your birthday or Christmas or
something I got it a couple years back
some of that [__] like the [__]
glorious bastards I thought it was
garbage yeah didn't like it either yeah
[__] uh the one with
uh crussell in it where he played the
bad guy that was pretty good yeah what
was that called the one where they were
all at the um they were crashing cars
into each other and [__] oh um bar death
death what's it called Death Proof death
proof that was the one well that was
initially him and Rodriguez that did it
pretty good that was like the two I like
that one movies yeah getting all into
his foot fetish he's foot fetishy
[__] his feet everybody's got
their own thing you know what I me okay
you have a shoe fetish so you can't you
can't really I like feet but feet are
second to shoes he likes feet in shoes
yeah whereas Tarantino just shoes yeah
he likes shoes that are like super
uncomfortable yeah they look like
they'll hurt look like they look like
they're uncomfortable with a woman they
look like they'd be uncomfortable if
they stepped on
me yeah for some reason it sounds like
they got to look weaponized yeah
weaponized shoes
yeah uh Cas is it Cas Le or cassen Ley
I'm not really sure if I'm pronouncing
your name correctly so please forgive me
you guys into David Lynch movies [__]
yeah I am totally into David Lynch
movies David Lynch is my favorite
director and M Halland Drive is probably
my favorite movie of all time or at
least in my top three I've watched that
movie four million times I even I did a
review on it by myself I think you were
out of town and I was like oh I'm gonna
do like a deep dive into malland drive
[__] because I'm like super obsessed
with that movie but yeah I like I love
[__] David Lynch all of his movies I
keep meaning to do because I bought the
whole [__] Twin Peaks thing you know
what I mean the whole box set that had
the um you know all the uh seasons of
the show and like the new season
that was on Showtime I think and I think
it had Twin Peaks firewalk with me like
the movie and everything and I was going
to do like a whole video of that but I
still haven't got around to it yet
because that's like a lot of hours of of
Television that I need to sit and watch
and I just haven't had time to do it yet
even though I've even though I bought it
like two years ago I still haven't had
time to like sit and do it but you know
what I mean at least I had time to like
finish up the last six ep the next six
episodes of Night Gallery because I've
been doing Night Gallery over on my
scares show and I'm just slowly going
through like six episodes at a time so I
got the whole script written for season
2 episodes 7 through 12 so that'll be
the next one I'm recording so that
should go up sometime this week probably
I don't know if I'm going to have time
to do it tomorrow but it'll be up
on Thursday or Saturday probably I'm
thinking but I was just glad I got all
of that done um yeah Zan said my brother
loves Once Upon a Time in Hollywood it's
funny to see it yeah it's like a hangout
movie like it's
but it's like but it's a good hang movie
yeah and I said before I'm
reiterate Tarantino is a great director
but I think he's off when he's off for
me but when he's doing that off [__]
he's trying to accomplish something else
he's trying to do some style that he saw
or whatever and it's not really for me
so some of his [__] I think is [__]
great other ones is just a Miss for me
but for other people they love it like
they really liked Kill Bill I didn't
like kill b i lik Kill Bill I saw in the
theater it's a kung fu movie he's trying
to do a kung fu movie I like Kung Fu
movies though yeah but I want my kung fu
movies to be
Chinese I got you that's that's fair
enough yeah yeah hateful eight was the
one you were talking about hateful eight
I love the hateful eight I thought was
very good I thought that was I love
Jennifer Jason yeah yeah yeah he was
real good I love her anyway he's on but
he see it's it's not I'm not saying I
don't like some of the reason why I
don't like some of his movies because I
don't like some of the genres he chooses
to do right so it's not so much the
movie if you like that genre then you'd
like it but I don't like that genre him
doing that
genre but ha late I thought was [__]
great yeah that was a lot of fun
especially the long there's a longer cut
I saw that I thought was even [__]
better yeah we reviewed that not too
long ago I'm pretty sure we watch like
the longer
cut yeah mango said he loves uma's feet
yeah yeah she has weird ass well they're
weird feet but they're kind of like cool
feet I can see why he's in they were
weird they were just kind of thin
they're just long and thin yeah which
some people have that I yeah I prefer a
foot that's kind of like short [__]
cute [__] baby feet I don't like that
big long ham not like actual baby feet
hamster feet like long hamster feet like
a hamster foot no wait you like my
little feet you got little baby feet I
have little baby feet they're you got
they're slightly flat footed though just
a little bit they are very yeah they are
flat footed yeah but they are little
yeah that's a southern thing a lot of
girls a lot of southern girls a little
bit I've always been flat footed a
little bitat you're not fully flat
footed though no but like mostly flat
footed yeah I noticed that when I was a
little kid yeah but like I said I never
really thought about it until yeah you
brought it up I think then I was like oh
okay I didn't realize that was weird no
yeah what's more common in Caucasians is
have a [__] very aggressive Arch no I
don't have that yeah yeah I super flaty
yeah and they're very small like I think
I only wear I could depending on the
shoe I can sometimes wear a size six
yeah but I usually wear a size seven um
yeah K Lee says mhal Drive is so
freaking great it blew my mind yeah I
could watch it over and over and over
again and I've read entire like essays
about the [__] like because there's all
kind of like essays about it I just I
[__] love saying he need to see The
Dead Zone dude you haven't even seen any
[__] carberg flicks and now you're
going on about dead oh that's right yeah
oh yeah so I because so he told me that
yeah and I was just kind of like o if
I'm new to Cronenberg he's seen the fly
cuz I love David kinberg so I'm sitting
really count I mean it does but that's
his most mainstream movie that was the
one that got him the most mainstream
acceptance before or since so I'm like
if I was new to Cronenberg like how
would I start I would probably start
with video Drome because that's his most
iconic then The Brood and then probably
The Brood yeah maybe dead ringers if
you're I mean that's more psychological
horror yeah video
drone yeah and he did The Dead Zone too
but like I said that doesn't quite count
cuz it's a Stephen King adaptation not
like his usual thing but you know what I
mean and I would recommend like saving
his older [__] like Shivers and um and
stuff like that like for
later but probably like his 80s stuff
yeah scanners is good too but it's just
kind of like it's oh I forgot about
scanners yeah that was 81 I would see
video drum brood in the scanners
scanners yeah don't worry about scanners
too that's not Chron yeah it was it
wasn't pile of [__] it wasn't good just
yeah I mean The Dead Zone with the one
with Christopher Watkin is a great movie
but I think if you're watching it being
familiar with cronenberg's work I don't
know if you'd necessarily know that was
a Cronenberg flick because it's a
Stephen King ad it's a it's one of the
best Stephen King adaptations ever it's
a great [__] movie but it's not super
Corin bergian you know that's all I'm
saying he made some weirder [__] later
like he made I'm I'm going to go to bat
for exist ends I know a lot of people
didn't like that movie but I was kind of
into it it's a little bit dated now um
but I kind of dug it I saw that in the
theater actually he said he was going to
watch brood first you can watch a brood
first either brood or video drum I
really like the brood yeah bro's good
too the end of it pretty just see The
Brood video drum and [__] scanners
you'll like those those three I like I
said I'm partial to dead
ringers um that came out of 1988 yeah
that's more psychological horror but it
does have some body horror elements in
it in the three movies that I I told you
about kerberg was getting into kind of
like body horror mixed with like
corporate horror it's about evil
corporations that are doing
experiments most of them like
genetically engineering people that have
metal powers in one of them or another
one's kind of like an evil Corporation
that's more like a cult that's making
addictive [__] BDSM porn that [__]
warps your body and your mind maybe it's
hard to
tell and The Brood is about a
[__] not really a corporation but a
little [__] self-help cult yeah
that's creating monsters with the mind
that's [__] really good man well it's
basically
like they're taking all of your negative
emotions like rage and stuff and it's
manifesting as actual babies babies yeah
yeah we which like I said I love the
ideas behind this [__] and honestly if
you haven't seen any because his son
makes movies too Brandon kerberg um and
we reviewed well be both of us together
reviewed infinity pool which I [__]
loved I thought that was fantastic but
he did two other ones and I think we
also reviewed his other movie
possessor yeah um that had Andrea
riseboro in it who was also in Mandy and
he also did another one called antiviral
which I think I just reviewed I think
that came out in 2012 but all of Brandon
kernberg's movies are also worth
watching if you haven't seen Mandy
that's a masterpiece God I love weird
horror movie all right Jen we we shut it
down I think we've covered everything on
reckon so I'm departed all right so as
zanada mentioned a long time ago uh the
show we're doing on Wednesday night is
about uh what's his name adolo constanzo
and the so-called Narco Satanist or
otherwise known as the Matamoros cult um
so we're going to be talking about that
like the Mexican cartel people that were
into Santa Ria and [__] that were
sacrificing people on okay so we're
going to be talking about that that's
what won in the poll so he said he was
going to uh send me a documentary about
that I got a couple other documentaries
that I already have like lined up in my
playlist that I got to watch and like I
got to read through some [__] tomorrow
about it but yeah that's what the show
is going to be about on Wednesday night
so hopefully you guys can join us for
that that should be nice and [__] up
um but yeah yes he says I'll send you a
really good documentary yeah send me
that because I'll I'll watch it later on
probably tomorrow or Wednesday morning
so yeah thanks everybody for dropping by
thank you again Zan for sending us The
Departed cuz like I said I had forgotten
how [__] great that movie was and I
had a I had a blast like re-watching it
and getting surprised by it all over
again so yeah we will be back on
Wednesday night uh so hopefully you guys
can join us for that good night